You go out to dinner.
People don't agree.
You like this, I like that.
You kind of ascribe that to me like maybe I'm not sophisticated,...
...or I have some moral problems that I don't understand good food.
But what people don't understand is we actually perceive things differently.
We all look differently and that has to do in part with how we're born,...
...and it has in part with what we do, with what we have.
Hair short, hair long and it's just the same for sense of taste.
They're inborn differences in genotype,...
...so there's proteins that sense the sugars on our tongue...
...that send a message to the brain.
And some people have protein,...
...there's not as much of those proteins where they're misshapen.
And those people don't actually perceive as much sweet from sugar.
Okay, so we got our four people and they're having dinner.
So they look their taste profile, genetic profile.
We could see these different patterns.